c'était une signature très attendu le 19
mars dernier
agnès pannier rue nash est valide le
contrat territoire d'industrie nord
franche comté
la secrétaire d'état ils voient un coup
d'accélérateur décisif pour l'avenir de
l'air urbaine c'est très simple madame
la présidente de région et le pilote
elle est dans l'oeil thiam volant les
industriels du territoire et
l'agglomération travaille avec elle pour
rechercher des solutions pour créer de
l'emploi résoudre des problèmes de
toutes natures et nous l'état nous
sommes là en position d'accompagnement
des expertises de facilitateur et
évidemment de financeurs à ses côtés la
présidente de région a donc le statut de
co pilote et elle compte bien en
profiter pour appuyer l'un de ses
projets phares créer un centre dédié aux
batteries électriques à quelques mètres
de l'usiné psa
ici il y a non seulement du foncier
disponible mais un écosystème totalement
adapté à la question de la construction
de batteries électriques de la
construction d'une filière de la du
recyclage la batterie électrique aussi
il y à un écosystème qu'il faut prendre
en considération
et donc voilà c'est l'occasion pour moi
de plaider cette cause auprès de la
ministre
124 contrats comme celui ci vont être
signés dans toute la france et pour la
première fois toutes les collectivités
locales semble aller dans le même sens
pour décrocher des financements
nationaux en est dans le cadre du pôle
métropolitain donc on est pour les cinq
territoires même cité suite de vos je
n'ai pas encore tous tu devais y va il
va rentrer très vite dedans et bien sûr
ça va être de travailler pour tous les
territoires
montbeliard belfort et rico
dell est vraiment de développer des
actions industrielles dans tous ces
territoires
en tout une quinzaine de projets sont
sur la table
parmi les pistes il y a le materner lab
du nom d'un ancien ingénieur peugeot
l'idée réhabiliter ce bâtiment de
maintenance désaffectée de psa pour en
faire un centre d'innovation et de
formation
on voudrait mettre des start up qui vont
imaginer là encore des choses nouvelles
des petits robots des des moyens de
manutention des choses comme ça que ces
startups elle puisse aller valider ce
qu'elles font finalement parce qu'elles
sont juste à côté de l'atelier
et puis on voudrait mettre en plus un
institut de formation parce qu'en plus
pour le cas 2.0 pour cette révolution
qui est la quatrième révolution
industrielle qui nous arrive il va y
avoir besoin de beaucoup de formations
autres objectifs du contrat requalifier
d'anciennes friches industrielles
une mesure qui intéresse beaucoup
fernand burkhalter
le maire d'héricourt y voient une
manière d'attirer de nouvelles
entreprises comme ce fut le cas d'hermès
venus s'installer ici il y a trois ans
dans une ancienne filature pour y créer
250 emplois
c'est une opportunité essentielle compte
tenu de notre projet de nos projets pour
le développement économique de la ville
est du pays d'héricourt pour faire venir
quoi là pour faire venir des entreprises
artisanales des entreprises de services
voire des entreprises médicale d'autres
idées sont aussi à l'étude
créer un institut de stockage de
l'hydrogène ou encore une cité de
l'industrie des projets qui pourrait
voir le jour d'ici quelques années si le
nord franche-comté transforme l'essai